we're
live
damn uh that was what's uh what's like
what do you think is like when you see a
kid you're like oh this guy is going to
be a great fighter like what is it that
you see in people is it like their
impulsiveness and they don't give a [__]
and like they hate for him it was just
his athleticism and his just
comfortability in the ring at such a
young age cuz I saw him fight when he
was 16 and 17 years old and most people
don't stick with fighting it's such a
tough sport
so then when I saw him when I was he was
18 years old still competing still being
comfortable in the ring I was like damn
he probably loves the sport and he's a
good athlete and he looks comfortable in
there so but you can see guys at the gym
like Young Bucks that are really good
and then in four or five years there's
not fighting anymore they're done it's
they're over it's [__] brutal they
don't want to train twice a day they
don't want to live that lifestyle so
it's so hard to say if you see someone
at a young age if they're going to be
good or not it's so hard to predict yeah
espe I mean being a comic too you
probably got to be really flat broke for
a long time yeah and suffering and
emotional abuse cuz it's like the worst
thing for a comedian is like social
embarrassment that's like we're very
sensitive people but it's like the
people that get hurt the most by social
embarrassments are the ones that do
comedy because we want to be able to
control that and and then you guys got
have the guys that like have been doing
comedy for like 5 years and then go on
kill Tony and kill Tony says you should
quit oh God Tony's ruthless up there huh
yeah I mean it's only a minute and you
can't really tell but sometimes you can
tell and you're just spinning your
wheels I'm I uh I'm I'm terrified of
having to do a minute D like as soon as
me too tonight as soon as your minute
ends do you get right back right into
creativity for the next week or is this
is there a certain day Tony said he has
a full Excel sheet just like [__]
thousands of jokes yeah I just write it
out um but yeah I mean usually on Monday
I'm just so relieved I do a bunch of
mushrooms and smoke a bunch of weed damn
every week yeah every Monday and after
yeah after and does a lot of your
creativity come from that no I think I
think what the drugs help me do is like
dull the pain and like the the stress
and then uh yes usually when I get high
and right that helps too but usually I
just do it just so I don't hate
myself yeah uh
I don't know it's just been kind of
rough lately I've been uh you know
feeling a little lonely and insecure and
I don't I personally if I had to guess
I'm not a [__] psychologist or a
doctor or anything but it's probably the
drugs I'm huge I love drugs I think
drugs are [__] great but I do think
it's you got to be careful doing like
there's a point where you need to just
be [__]
clear-headed but I think you know doing
mushrooms do smoking too much weed and
all that will cause anxiety and then you
[__] don't sleep good and then you
don't eat good and then it just spirals
downhill and then you don't perform good
and you don't perform good yeah I agree
with you are you ever you think about
health uh yeah yeah when you're
sick I should not do what I did last
night did J what did you do after we
left cuz we went to the strip club for
for what a little bit 20 30 45 what' you
do after yeah we I just went home with
my girlfriend and she was like um you
know she didn't like the strip club no
she didn't like it but she did uh she
get horny from it
yeah I love that and so uh we had a
little bit of a jerking off session damn
just straight jerk yeah she's going
through an issue right now with her
vaginal is that is that infection no I
don't think so I think she has a yeast
infection I'm hoping she's getting
tested but yeah I mean uh yeah we just
we just went home and crashed she got
you gave you a jerky though with coconut
oil or just raw just with Lube dude you
we got to use coconut oil it is the best
oh my God it's so good Lube kind of
dries out it's just like it dries out
coconut oil will change your life even
personal jerks solo jerks fantastic it's
probably a lot healthier for your [__]
yeah that [__] [__] Lube you can [__]
her with coconut oil good extra virgin
organic coconut
oil I remember the first time I took my
girl to a strip club too she was just
like what the [__] cuz it was a you
could you could eat steak at the strip
club so I'm eating a steak and there's
like fat butt cheeks right in front of
me and I'm looking this Portland Oregon
yeah a AC crop you really you've been
there yeah that's crazy small world
perverts huh yeah yeah I don't strip
clubs are weird bro we we were there
sober and I'm like what the [__] these
girls are just [__] and some of the
[__] they do I'm like that's not sexy
but maybe if I was like [__] up it' be
sexy well when they're perking their
butts like they're just looking for a
[__] I think it's sexy you with your
girl there you know how to act no when
they're clapping their heels together
and their leg like they're it's just
yeah like it's not that hot or they're
on the pole the pole is not like super
sexy to me yeah I think it's just
tradition they just like strip club like
the pole they just have like a way of
being sexy and they just think that's
how to do it I definitely left a little
horny though I'm not going to say I
didn't you know what I mean there are
some beautiful women there she did seem
a little run down but it's
okay that's like Tim's type of girl he
goes through he goes for the girls that
have some good insecurities so like he
feels better about himself right like
that
sometimes H [__] what a random pod
though dude yeah I know we've been cuz
when did I remember hearing about kill
Tony on Rogan a couple times remember I
tried to watch it and I just watched it
like a little bit where Tony just
[__] roasted someone who did bad and
I felt bad I'm like I don't know if I
liked that then you were like just give
it another shot just give it another
shot and then I watched an episode and
then I literally binged watch I don't
know how many if you look at my YouTube
and you can go to like kill Tony and
look how many past ones I've watched
I've watched so [__] many such a good
ass idea yeah you just binged it when
you were just binged watch from it was
well I went too far back to where the
quality wasn't as good and I already
spoiled myself with the newer ones so
it's was like kind of hard to watch to
where I was like [__] I got to find it
to where it was like the quality was up
and then I watched it from there but
I've watched a [__] ton
yeah that's how I was watching it before
I got on it it's just like my friends
you know that's funny I got to get with
my friends again you can just press play
and they're always there for you do you
really do you think about like how long
you think you'll be on there or forever
as long as I can yeah cuz at this point
like so many people are like talking
[__] that I just want to like just [__]
with them keep proving them wrong keep
showing up yeah just annoy them as much
as possible do you ever hang out with
William
Montgomery uh not really um he's he's
very never stop sorry I want to hit one
of those
tonight I can't wait to see it man it's
going to be crazy um but yeah he's we
usually hang out after the show at mits
we just get drunk together and M A Bar
yeah it's the one right underneath it's
where everyone's hanging does Rogan pop
into the mother [__] much yeah he's
there every Tuesday Wednesday usually
Thursday and he does his shows there oh
we'll have to go Tuesday tomorrow that'
be sweet sure we're going on Rogan
Wednesday nice yeah yeah that' be
awesome that's that's how Tony likes to
do it he's like do my podcast first and
then do Rogan Hans Rogan Hans who kill
Tony than Rogan um yeah know that's
[__] cool Austin's a cool place I
haven't really seen too many [__] which
I've been wanting to see a couple you'll
see a bunch tonight I kill tonyx hor too
or not god dude that make me nervous on
stage I'm like I'm pretty nervous
they're usually with a partner I don't
give a [__] no I do I do I respect
boundaries you get more nervous around
women than men I don't yeah oh yeah
girls oh they got me hella thinking I'm
going to be nervous sitting up on stage
though if I go on tonight yeah that's
going to be crazy do you know do you
know who else is up there or who there
no I was going to ask you I have no idea
they don't she doesn't tell me anything
do you see Tony much like throughout the
week uh yeah every time I go to the
Mother Ship he's there um but yeah
usually we used to hang out a lot more
cuz I was doing a bunch of the shows at
the Vulcan and then we go to the karaoke
the karaoke tomorrow is crazy dude yes
that would be fun karaoke God except for
my voice a little like a little
different right now usually like sound
good no it's jokes are you like an
artist do you do like other things I can
draw oh damn no I can't I look a [__]
[__] um artistically I literally can
fight and that's about it I can't really
do I mean you can do good some sports oh
there's Sports in general I can do them
all I like to think but you much you do
Sports yeah I used to do Jiu-Jitsu and
then I hurt my neck U I did it for like
a year and a half damn really did you
call it after that yeah I didn't want to
but you would you would have liked going
to Tim's gym uh training down there I
know I I feel like that would have been
amazing but would be sweet yeah once I
get better I've been in ing stem cells
in my neck from Wells away or W to well
I'm doing that tomorrow hell yeah yeah
Brigham's a great guy yeah I'm going to
do some have you been noticing a
difference yeah it shifted from my left
to my right you do got I don't think
that's good you do got a pretty thick
neck thank you it's my insec it's like
one of my only insecurities my neck just
so skinny it's embarrassing I mean it's
not really a concern though cuz you're
such a you keep them far away but
exactly cuz once people punch me
[Music]
I well they think I'm closer than I
really am got a is there a pretty big
comedy scene in Phoenix yeah they got
like four comedy clubs they got the
stand up live CB live or whatever we've
been to a couple we live kind of far
away but God comedy I've always thought
of myself as a [__] comedian but then
I couldn't write I could never like
write jokes M yeah you're more like
shitty comedian you're like a actor a
comedic actor or something
I mean I think comedy is like pretty
accessible to anyone yeah I agree
everyone can be funny I agree even if
they're just not funny you can train
yourself be that's the one thing you got
to be funny a little bit I think just
naturally a little bit funny but what is
funny I don't like people
like that's probably what I would say
you know get giving getting a laugh out
of someone I think what it is is like a
[__] you kind of thing like [__] this
I'm going to change it and make it
different I think that's funny yeah
jackass or Punk or whatever punk was
good throw Punk old punk was good I mean
you could be the funniest [__] dude
in the room but then you're just in a
room full of Kens or something yeah it's
all about the audience too like if the
audience doesn't laugh then technically
that's not funny I swear that's the only
way I got [__] in high school was being
funny same like I didn't think I was
like cute or anything maybe a little bit
but did you ever get [__] in high
school no I didn't even get [__] in
college I had to wait till after college
so the recent [__] kind of newer for
you yeah damn that's a new world yeah it
sucks when you we were just talking
about like God it' be sweet if we
couldn't get as much [__] as we could
because then you wouldn't crave it as
well maybe you would
Schmitty yeah I don't know but then
you'd be like when you go out you're
like okay we feel like we can get [__]
but if you were ugly you'd be like yeah
it's not really realistic
yeah it's a desire too much on my mind
yeah it's really distracting it takes
the devil yeah that's why I'm thinking
about switching my uh beliefs so you
have a girlfriend now so when you're
when you're maybe your girlfriend's not
around and you get horned up do you just
have a Jack or do you just try to switch
your your your thoughts I jack it I jack
it a lot like it helps you at least
clear it up for a little bit yeah it
gets it out of the system and do you
think from jacking it so much could be
why you're
sad I I do find myself I bust more than
a couple nuts a day I'm I'm feeling a
little low on energy yeah depending on
what you're looking at imagine not Jack
this guy imagine not keeping that Chi
that energy that energy source from not
busting you don't do that for 3 4 days
you feel like a different you [__]
yeah feel like a bull you're angry well
it could be just want to [__] anything
you just feel good energy but if you're
busting nuts sometimes I have to to get
my mind right yeah I mean with Reddit
you ever you ever checked out Reddit
porn I mean that's that's porn no I
usually I have a bookmark I bookmark
everything I like and then I just scroll
through it and click a random one and
I'll go underneath the recommended
videos that's good I was watching an
Asian massage one the other day oh those
are my favorite it was good rustic
rustic TR trombone you like those yeah
it was fire what's rustic trombone
explain it I think you get a rim job
from the back oh okay and then jerk off
yeah the from the back rusty trombone I
was looking into milking tables in
Phoenix and they have a few you know
what that is yeah I've never had a milk
a little [__] comes out of a table
little [__] well it's our little [__] we
do it yeah so there's a lady who's
supposedly an expert in Phoenix but it
looks like the website was made by her
so I'm a little bit nervous I want I say
we send in one of our boys first yeah a
little test [__] yeah little test
rub you ever go to the clubs much like
Club clubs and like no oh that' be fun
to go to clubs huh yeah I should next
yeah well have a good time yeah it's not
usually wasn't my vibe coming up dude
you should come to uh Vegas for
Halloween we're doing this party at
Resorts World zuk this club should we
invite [__] DJ why is it DJ Hans cam
cuz uh I was posting like something
about like you know Biden is gay or
whatever and then they're like you're
that's it's not funny you're supposed to
be a comedian it was Hans Kim comedian I
was like okay I'm a [__] DJ now I can
post whatever I want DJs are allowed to
yeah I thought comedians were allowed to
I know but they were like hey you're a
comedian this has to be funny all the
time and I was like I don't want to be
funny all the time I'd rather be a DJ so
when you were saying Biden's gay you
were being serious not funny yeah I
wasn't doing it in a funny way I was
just making statements about America and
stuff yeah I don't really understand
politics too much yeah I don't I don't
think I think ideally you wouldn't have
to think think about that and you could
just focus on yourself but how old are
you uh 34 34 yeah I'm 33 I was I was
looking it up I put in Hans Kim age and
it said 28 but it also said from North
Korea so I'm like I think it's the wrong
[__] Hans the internet doesn't know
anything I know this they say my net
worth is like $2
million really yeah that's not even
close and they have it all over that
Tony's gay cuz I'm like I don't think
he's gay but Mar's like I think he is so
I was like it and have it all over that
he is I'm like [__] is that just the
David Lucas Tony [__] is that why
everyone says that yeah he looks gay he
he has sex with lots of women I believe
that yeah not that he's hot
but he's just got it he's got that Riz
yeah and plus he has the show which
helps oh yeah yeah with girls and stuff
like before you had your girlfriend
would you try to like say we're going to
go to coffee we're going to go to dinner
or would you kind of just give her a a
compliment to know what what you were
looking for what do you mean for my
girlfriend to be like hey before before
when you you were trying to pull puss oh
like hey you want to get a cup of coffee
or would you say hey you want to come
over yeah I would just be like hey uh
you want to go do an open mic together
oh so you'd kind to go on a little date
flirt around a little bit I that's fun
go to a comedy show yeah try to finger
somewhere in public yeah you know mean
that way that's like a my show and it's
like Oh I'm a I'm a
Starly yeah but then you're always
around comedy shows and it's like oh is
this all you do like you don't do
anything for fun well that probably is
for fun too you probably love being
there yeah it's my friends it's like my
circle I get to hang there try to have
sex there yeah that's sweet it seems
like a lot of I mean our most Comics
pretty like intelligent and seems like
they are yeah I think so they're
intelligent in some ways yeah and then
really stupid in other ways yeah in
terms of like taxes and stuff [__] oh
don't even bring that up I got an email
today about taxes I know makes want a
puke I know I spent way too much on
taxes and they want more now they want
$5,000 more you write off your
watch I the business expense yeah I mean
I've brought it up so many times on the
show yeah [__] yeah what a joke about it
so what kind of what kind of diet do you
have like when you wake up in the
morning what's your usually first meal I
used to do all carnivore like in my van
I'd cook up like pork ribs and stuff but
now I just eat burgers and fast food and
whatever I can dude that that has a huge
part in the way you feel even mentally
emotionally what you eat makes you feel
however you feel what do you try to eat
you guys get like elk um I for the most
part like every morning is eggs I have
chickens we have fresh eggs uh maybe
some eggs and bacon for for breakfast
then for lunch usually like if I'm in
Camp it's something specific every time
but for lunch we've been doing like
depends if I train or not if I don't
train I'll haven't even been eating till
dinner then we'll have like steak rice
broccoli chicken like something
something simple nothing too crazy we
definitely [__] have like uh we'll
we'll have like a breakfast burritos if
we go out or bagle sandwiches [__] like
that but that's more of like a little
treat rather than everyday [__] yeah so
you take care of your body even when
you're just done fighting have to yeah
try to I think most Fighters don't but I
think that just it's going to have
effect on your longevity I think yeah
want to fight for a long time training
twice a day there's already so much
inflammation in your body so if you're
eating bad foods it's just adding more
inflammation it's just like breaks your
body down so easy where did you watch
the the my fight at oh downstairs the
Alro fight yeah on the big TV oh that's
right you were telling me your girl yeah
we went to go Thai food and then we
missed it they ran out to grab their
Uber Eats and missed
it [__] I know we to rewind but we
didn't know what happened so it was
surprise for us oh really yeah fire so
what's uh what's your plan for Austin
are you guys going to go crazy tonight
no I'm I'm I'm getting stem cells in the
morning 9:00 a.m. so I'm not going to do
nothing too crazy night going to go how
how late the show 8:30 to 10 8:30 to
10:30 damn so we'll probably yeah just
hang out it' be cool to just hang out at
the mother ship for a bit and then try
to get some decent sleep tonight um and
then tomorrow Tuesday I got stem cells
9:00 a.m. then we don't have any plans
Tuesday maybe get a little
massage nice yeah not a lot of Asians in
Austin I don't like that I love Asians
yeah I haven't I've never really been
with a beautiful Asian
yeah no uh yeah that's on my bucket list
want a nice dark chocolate girl too yeah
what's your go-to just kind of white you
like white uh I like Hispanics m I think
they're the perfect color they got
amazing bodies and beautiful faces I
agree I mean I like white girls just
because they're pampered and princesses
and they're just like what a woman
should be is just not worried about
anything what about blacks ooh I like
some black girls but a lot of black
girls are overweight I think and they
seem to really like me on on Tinder it's
like that's all black girls and gay guys
is your thing no just big black girls
you're meaty you got a lot of uh meat on
the bone maybe that yeah I wonder if
that's it just thck and it seems like
you're cool with anything like people
could just go crazy around you and you'd
be like
chill yeah hell yeah I like that yeah I
don't discriminate when it comes to
women I like I mean they're they're cute
they're I like foreign girls a lot
accents mhm oh you ever been to Miami
yeah I do I uh I don't really do well
there I don't think Miami is my vibe
because what in what way cuz I'm not hot
as as they are you throw a [__] chain
on though
G just ride a Toyota with the fin on it
yeah is there is that your scooter
downstairs yeah bro that thing's sick as
[__] yeah we used to rock scooters all
the time yeah it's so convenient you
don't feel like you're wasting anything
you're just like I'm I want to get
myself over there that's all that I'm
going to get over there get over there
[__] cuz there's a lot of stuff in
this area around you here yeah it's
close to the downtown how far is it from
Mothership it's like 7 minutes on the
highway yeah is the rent like crazy
expensive here it's like 1050 for me
1050 and you're and how many guys live
here three so it's like 3,000 for the
whole house that's not bad yeah not bad
it's really really livable this place is
like yeah that's why I hate like LA and
New York it's cuz everyone squeezed in
they're like oh we can exploit them here
yeah [__] that yeah it's like once
there's so many people you just become
like a number and it's easy to like [__]
you
over yeah but uh what do you guys think
about public
transit got in trouble in the public
transit before and I was actually joking
with this girl and she thought I was
sexually harassing with her like a bus
yeah so I I had to take a leave from the
transit for a little bit when was this
you got kicked off all transit uh I was
in eighth grade eighth grade yeah you
just had a traumatic experience on a bus
it wasn't too bad just when when the
cops were contacting me that's where it
got bad and I wasn't I honest to God
didn't even go too far with this girl I
was joking around let me suck in your
tits I'm
kidding kidding yeah I got some trouble
in in middle in high school middle
school in the bus but I I don't know if
I've ever been on a bus since it's like
a great place for trouble because
everyone's squeezed in together no one
wants to be there you could flip a
finger in E slip a little finger in Easy
over you're
saying yeah like a Japan oh that's where
we want to go we want to go bad you've
never been no they'd love you there I
they like that's the issue I think cuz
you know like you are skinny and like
they're like oh look this house they
wouldn't like him yeah they wouldn't
like you they' be like you're too fat
really no I don't think so you have red
hair you look like a character it's
about like but if I'm too fat I'm too
fat slim down bud maybe they like it
maybe some of the skinny girls want like
a big there fat asian
yeah like sumos there's probably not
female
sumos that would be kind of cool though
are there any female sumos would you
[__] a [__] yes oh me too I would
actually I would actually have a great
time doing that that would be cool
there's that hot one that lives like on
Insta a couple sexy ones yeah she was
catfishing us we were trying to get on
on no no that was a different but yeah a
sexy one but it's like they're the
hottest midgets just look like normal
people as as much as possible yeah yeah
true so you wouldn't want the one like
with actual the [__] face small person
like with the giant Cranium it's like
your [__] mega mind yeah getting
brained from brain getting Little D well
you wouldn't no I don't think so I mean
I'd do it I don't know if hard yeah I
could you're four bumps deep though just
to say something on kill Tony about it
yeah exactly damn so they don't like
thicker men in Japan
about that sucks you can still come with
me let watch me [__] tear it
up I think Japanese people love like the
martial arts so they would love MMA you
know people yeah they're freaks about it
too they had like the pride [__] like
putting like skinny guys against fat
guys yep oh that was legendary I missed
that missed that [__] yeah before [__]
this coffee before all the [__] woke
police were like hey he's going to get
permanent neck and iny like that I know
make weight classes yeah yeah weight
classes I'm glad there's weight classes
I don't want to fight big guys how much
would it cost for you to get in the cage
for a little Rumble time uh and it's an
even match even match my same experience
level yep I would want someone with less
experience than you have any experience
year and year and a half of what about
you vers Tony
kickboxing I wouldn't do it just because
I like my career yeah that's true so I
don't want to say anything bad about
Tony but if someone was Tony sized and
uh you know then I would love to do that
I guess put the boots to
him take out all my frustration what
about you versus Brian
Simpson uh I think he's got military
training ah and extra muscle yeah he's
black so yeah that's I mean they can
jump high you for sure you can see
things that I can't see he's just
trickier do you listen to Rogan's pod
much yeah I love it that's how I got
into comedy really yeah damnn that's
cool yeah I've been listening to it for
like 10 years at least at least 15 I
would guess it's crazy how you just
three a week 3 hours a piece about it's
like there's so much [__] to listen
to is it three a week now I think it's I
think it is back in the day used to be
every weekday five times a week 3 hours
each I think it's about three a week
that's such a crazy stamina like he
takes like the training that you guys do
for like physical stuff into the mind
it's wild so impressive like oh that's
what the these guys are doing in their
Arena and Joe's like the conduit to show
us like oh we need to get our [__]
together cuz we could be working a lot
harder that's like us sitting here for
another [__] two and a half hours
being a we probably could though yeah we
could yeah Joe's like black belt
podcaster yeah yeah he really his mind
he's always there it never lags yeah
there's never a point where it's like
his mental fatigue sh sets in yeah God
damn that's impressive yeah what do you
got going on the rest of the time what
time is it 5:30 we got kill Tony around
8 8:30 yeah just chilling for the rest
of the time yeah I'm going to try to
write try to prepare try to see if I can
come come up with something else damn
cuz I don't know you're not you're not
feeling too comfortable at your minute
tonight or what no yeah I wish it was
better but you know yeah it is a week
you never know those those ones could be
banging yeah sometimes it surprises me
dude comedy is so [__] impressive to
me I know especially going up first when
the audience is just like tell us what
comedy is and they expect you cuz
everyone that's there has probably seen
it before like it's Hans Kim we expect a
little giggle but honestly sometimes
even if you guys don't kill it the
interview can make up for it yeah for
sure but uh yeah that puts us in the
moment it's like okay you did your
minute now we're in this room and we can
just say anything so it's like let's
let's talk about what the audience wants
to talk about yeah the craziest thing
you could say right now like when you're
doing your bigger shows and stuff do you
ever wake up and you're just really not
in the mood to do it no I'm usually in
the mood to do it but I'm afraid I'm
scared I'm like you know like uh that
chel sun and quote where he's like I'm
relieved at the end when it when it's
over it's like oh thank God it's over
relief yeah yeah it's sort of like that
feeling that's how fighting is
yeah yeah I once uh met BJ Penn and
compared comedy to fighting and Tony was
like don't do
that yeah I mean just I guess all
performing is s in a sense right isn't
it crazy that it's like a performing art
like what fighting is yeah comedy's
[__] yeah I I writing dude I always
try to like if I think of something that
could be funny I like put in my notes
think about it I'm like I just couldn't
turn that into a joke I think writing is
like a lot of self-love you got to love
your ideas and be like come on this is a
good idea give it the energy and time to
put it because if you have like a shitty
idea and you put energy and time into it
you just feel like a complete [__]
[__] so then it's like you got to like
love yourself and like make yourself
take risks and like honor the ideas that
you come up with and respect your brain
do you ever write something down and
then think it's kind of funny and then
look at it later and be like what the
[__] yeah that's all my notes right now
I've just been looking through it like
this sucks this sucks ah it's weird
something could because sometimes when
you're [__] stoned like I'll tweet
something when I'm stoned and then I'll
be sober the next day be like what the
[__] I say that yeah some sometimes
you're in the mind state where you're
like this is funny but then if you're
outside of that mind State it's not
funny yeah and sometimes you come with
something in a mind State and even
outside of another that mind state is
still funny to you so it's just like it
really you can never know even like
Brian rean someone who's been doing it
30 years he he thinks something is funny
but you know you're stuck in your brain
you can't get out of it and see it
objectively until you say it on stage
and see it in the faces of the people
[__] I bet just being around like all
these highle Comics now and being
friends with all of them I bet you've
leveled up just so much yeah I feel like
that I feel like just my presence yeah
do you think having to write a minute
every week takes away from
writing full
sets
um like having that stress like I have
to [__] get a good minute but I'm
like I actually don't and it helps it I
think it's like motivates me to write
cuz otherwise I'd be a lazy ass
[__] just like everyone else
just try to be like well something will
come to me just surfing on your phone or
watching shows or YouTube or yeah and
then just going up there and doing bits
that I've been doing for a month month
and a half and be like this is new stuff
is that what a lot of lazy Comics do
yeah I could see that like well I'm
comfortable with this I know I can get a
little giggle out of it I can see that
it's so so scary to try new stuff and so
comforting to do old stuff I bet like
this is comedy this is me killing that's
comedy but it's like you got to you got
to keep that River fresh you don't want
to stagnate damn you think you'll ever
do like a special yeah I mean my agent
was telling me today like I mean I I'm
already burned out with so many markets
I've been touring like crazy so it's
like if I want to go back I have to have
a new hour and if I have a new hour why
don't I just put this one out like I
don't think I'm the Best comedian in the
world so I don't feel like comfortable
putting out a special but I'm like
whatever you know like I'm I need to put
it out anyways they' probably all felt
that way yeah yeah for specials I just
feel like you know I have so much more
to more to go I'm not really I don't
want to put it out I don't know like
would you be like would you say you're
like a like a purple or a brown belt in
comedy comedy so it's white white blue
brown purple brown brown I say purple
white blue purple brown black yeah
purple damn that's pretty sweet yeah but
even if you put it out like you're
[__] your fans will like it I mean
like you don't got to try to break the
[__] records I mean I have a clip of
me doing 10 15 minutes that has a
million views so I'm like that's good
enough that gives me the [__] you
know ego to be like I'm a comedian would
you do would you would you want to do it
on Netflix or just drop it on your
YouTube I would love to do it on Netflix
because that way people ask you to do it
I wasn't just like hey here's a special
everyone watching I want to be asked to
do it but you know we're asking you put
it
out it I record all my shows that I do
on the road nice so do you watch them
back or you just have them saved up you
watch I watch them back and I try to
clip any crowd work nice but I'm so lazy
I haven't done that mhm I've been with
my girl a lot so [__] godamn you ever
buy her anything like nice and expensive
plane tickets I have a travel with me
that is [__] expensive yeah that's
probably nice and comforting having her
just to hang out eat with and [__] dude
you could use you could use AI post your
video put your CLI your clip do you
upload them to YouTube unlisted yeah you
could literally copy and paste that URL
into to Opus Pro or some [__] say F find
me a 30 second clip that about whatever
joke you did and it'll make a clip for
you within like 5 seconds then you can
hell yeah cuz if you start posting a
bunch of [__] on Tik Tok do you post on
Tik Tok ever I do yeah a lot or just a
couple times a couple times you need to
be posting a lot and then your [__]
your [__] will go up for sure yeah
that's just an algorithm that's just
straight math yeah they don't try to
censor it at all yeah you need to
[__] post the more you po I mean it's
free to post
you know what I mean it's like it's post
post post post Malone it's like [__]
your own commercial you can post a
commercial on NBC you never know which
one I mean people surf Tik Tok they see
you fun get a good good laugh get a
follow I don't know do you ever think
about like posting like a clip of you
like [__] schooling someone like
[__] Nikki Rod does all the time oh
just like in the training rooms yeah
um yeah we don't record as much as I I
wish we recorded all of our rounds like
those guys do um but I yeah I mean there
I definitely have a lot of [__] on there
like [__] like that but for the most
part it's like you don't they're your
buddies and you train with them you
don't want to embarrass them just I mean
they [__] you up too sometimes you're
not going to post that so it's hard to
say but sometimes some shits just so
sweet you just got to post it and
depends if they're competing at a high
level too or if they got a competition
coming up you don't want to post that
kind of stuff but yeah or like the UFC
fights like little exchanges that most
people might have missed yeah I mean
it's It's Tricky with us in the UFC
because ESPN owns the rights to the
fights so it's like you have to be
careful post and [__] a lot of Fighters
just post anyway um but ESPN owns the
rights to even those clips on Instagram
and stuff I posted a lot on this last
one because UFC right after my fight
posted it everywhere oh yeah which is
they've never done that before so I kind
of feel okay posting those ones but It's
Tricky yeah you got to Suess it out like
what the Vibes are from the head hun we
yeah we don't own that footage so we I
mean it's me fighting in there but I
technically don't own that footage and
can get in trouble for posting it which
is weird I don't think really anybody
has but they've definitely asked us like
asked Fighters not to that's some mtown
[__] what's mtown it's like the the in
Nashville or something they had like a
bunch of black artists they would like
sign them to like really crazy contracts
that like take away the rights to
everything oh [__] yeah contracts or you
sign contracts or you read them you read
them or you just sign them I don't have
any contracts right now even one with
your manager yeah my agent is just like
out there doing things for me and I give
him money that's nice happy how long you
been doing your pod uh I've been doing
it on and off I mean it's not like an
official pod I just like you know just
chatting with Hans yeah whenever I want
to chat with someone um good setup I
mean [__] who else shoots in here
just me my roommates sometimes shoot in
here Brian Simpson and ass mod sometimes
shoot in here damn do you guys ever just
you should just get in here [__] hot
box
bunch of drugs click the cameras on I
wish we got to do we got to do that I
don't know that's started just [__]
turn the camera on let's [__] get
[__] up sh [__] I mean we're comedians
right yeah but I don't know uh MC Brian
and Assan like they they're more
protective of their you know brand and
image than I am I just like post
everything just Reckless yeah yeah I
don't care this is who I am mhm but uh
yeah I mean I love that uh Joe pave the
way for all of us crazy I know we we
want to get you on our pod when you come
to Phoenix be amazing I love your pod
we've been poding for about 5
years yeah so we've been that shit's fun
yeah once a week [__] talk [__] we
usually recap
fights yeah talk about CHS people want
to know like what it's like cuz no one
is doing this besides you know the
people that you guys are around all the
time so it's like I'm around comedians
all the time but I forget like not
everyone is trying to say the funniest
[__] and in conversation all the time
that's how I literally feel like well
we've always been yeah I mean in in even
around being around I mean we we get a
little bit too loose lipped on our pod
sometimes and talk about just personal
[__] which who we don't really care but
even talking to Dana he's like you got
to just keep your personal life private
and it's like [__] we would just want to
let loose I think that's a generational
thing I think like the older generation
doesn't understand really yeah but it is
true like it is very it could c a lot of
damage sometimes and they're like why do
you do that but then like people love
the access and love getting that's the
thing it's like we started this pod just
being like let's just [__] talk now
we're like all right now let's start
monitoring ourselves I hate that it
sucks but he's becoming such a superstar
that people go back five years ago to
our pods and start clipping [__] and
it's like definitely say it's [__] up
[__] yeah but but I feel like if I'm a
good person like that's what really
matters if I say some stupid [__] yeah
like no you're say you're going to say
you've never thought [__] up [__] you
just didn't say it so difference do you
like dark humor yeah yeah that's black
people jokes yeah yeah exactly
no we probably crossed the line a couple
times yeah never that what was that
Daniel spaz or what was that guy's name
remember that dark humor specially we
watched I forgot something like that
something [__] he's I think he's out of
the country SL yeah that British dude
yeah we watched some dark humor [__] on
him it's one of his specials and it was
funny as [__] yeah that's what comedy is
for it's not to go to the grocery store
it's to go to the morg oh
yeah yeah I feel that I feel that that's
we're going to probably get some [__]
velvet tacos after this ooh I think
that's a good place I we've went there a
couple times right mhm [__] do you
usually do do you do caffeine much or no
just mushrooms yeah so what about no no
caffeine yeah really really yeah no
caffeine I'm surprised I'm surprised you
like the booger sugar then I don't I
don't like it that much I did it like
every now and then but it became a whole
thing and I was like okay that could be
my thing just like the way it smells
yeah I don't really like it I it smells
decent yeah I mean I I don't I I need to
do a lot of it to feel it I don't feel
like I do it right if I've ever done it
I've never had but if I ever did just a
little bit would get me going
yeah I've never done it but I do like it
yeah I've never done it I love that [__]
this going to cliffed up I've never done
that [__] snorted and yeah it's like
when you uh smoke weed for the first
time you don't get high cuz you don't
know how to do it correctly oh God it's
like I I remember the first time I got
high high as [__] him and his buddy
Frank I black I greened out I was laying
on the floor laying on an Xbox
controller and it was so uncomfortable
but I couldn't move anything and him and
his buddy kept saying get up sugar
you're driving we're going to the store
and I was like I can't drive but I
couldn't move like get up we're driving
I'm like [__] cuz this [__] would be
so wild we trained twice in one day and
he'd come back to the apartment still
just like let's do something 19 20 years
old and against weed so I finally was
able to talk him into weed I'm like dude
a lot of good athletes a lot of good
athletes do the weed it's like
beneficial for us so once he started
smoking he started just getting [__]
dumb get bomb ribs and I just be laying
on the flooor just like last night dude
we smoked this joint last night holy
[__] I swear I saw the devil in his eyes
it was [__] you do much smoking weed
yeah every day yeah pretty much pretty
much so yeah you ever smoked out of one
of those volcanoes yeah God I like those
it doesn't hurt it's just air it's so
good yeah that's all I really use right
now I love the high from that cuz then
it seems like I mean if you're doing
healthy [__] it seems like a more of a
clear-headed high where you can still be
creative still think compared to a bong
rimp oh yeah nicey yeah cuz that shit's
like straight to the Dome yeah straight
to the Domer speaking of when was last
time we got a bee uh this morning from
my girlfriend nice like add from your
girlfriend just in case she listens
without asking and she just got up and
did that isn't that a nice gesture that
is a nice them it shows dedication God
it makes me love my girl so much more
when she does that yeah it's like the
way that they dive on it too it's like
oh this like yeah and maybe acting like
they like it yeah
oh does yours not actually like it no
she actually really does no it doesn't
seem like it you watch
no but it's like a very symbolic gesture
it's like shaking hands it's like Hello
nice to meet you should be as often as
that you don't get much morning BJs do
you morning I have a three-year-old two
and a halfy old so no I don't get any
morning BJs I would hate morning BJs cuz
that's when I have to pee so then it's I
would like to pee first he just pees in
her mouth oh no I no yeah morning BJ is
not really I mean not much of a thing
for me anymore yeah sucks you want kids
yeah I want to raise children and train
them to be like me
depressed the king of sadness depressed
the king of sadness oh
what what fights are you most forward
looking to or do you watch UFC much
other than you got any fights you're
most excited about coming up I don't
watch it like that yeah I'm not that big
into it but when it comes up like oh big
fight coming up I'll watch watch like
joh Jones versus Dee is coming up in
November [__] that decent I'm excited
for that one um Charles alera versus
Islam 2 is in October it's coming up
okay yeah there's some decent fights you
you like music much uh a little bit jazz
your
mood I I feel like once you get older
like I slowly started to like not get
impacted as hard by music which I think
is sad oh throw it might be the drugs
you're doing smoke some weed and throw
on some Creed yeah doesn't don't drugs
help with the I think I do think it does
but when you're doing so many drugs it's
like your chemical balances are just off
you just need to get back to Baseline
which make take a couple couple weeks of
withdrawals maybe a little bit how often
do you do drugs now I I use the volcano
every night I smoke every night but when
I'm at home in my routine I really don't
smoke that much um mushrooms not very I
did do some mushrooms recently but
before that a long time cocaine never
done that never done that so it's like
end of the day you just I smoke well
right now after this fight I've been
smoking during the day too a little bit
volcano hitting a volcano during the day
and then at night but yeah weed pretty
much every day but not a ton not like as
much as people think I do
you ever done Molly Molly how'd you feel
I feel great it's like what you think a
drug is when you're a kid yeah that's a
good way to put it not that I've done it
but if I did I feel like it would that
resonate if I did drugs as a kid it'd be
Molly that's probably my favorite club
drug if I did it it's scary though it's
sort of like acid cuz you know it's like
chemical it's not like a plant it's like
MD yeah you get overdose on Molly I
think I've tried you tried man if you
get some good Pier stuff though and you
and you do
and you don't get maybe you don't mix it
with a bunch of alcohol and you just do
that with some water I mean it is
dangerous doing around girls though it's
like [__] if you oh yeah you get a
little handsy not that you just fall
love oh and then you can't come no no I
never have an issue with
that I've never yeah I don't really I've
never done that [__] but if I did but if
I did I'd [__] yeah same take a bath
with a
[__] jokes um yeah I feel like Molly's
like makes you see colors and stuff so
we got to bring Hans to [__] zuk in V
he he would have fun do you want to come
yeah Halloween we'll we'll try to set
something up that would be fun you can't
bring your girl though we're not
bringing ours oh [__] it's a guy's trip
it's a guy's trip H yeah
so she's all in the hotel
room would you be allowed to go or if we
invited you um I'll have to ask her
probably not but they're they're they're
pretty fresh though so months yeah
that's fresh yeah but it's guys and trip
yeah but seven months and you tell your
girl you're trying to gain trust and
stuff and you say hey we're going on a
guy's trip to Vegas like that shouldn't
be an issue I got to make her sick of me
so that she's like please go yeah or
just treat her really good and say hey I
just want to go and have a trip with the
boys I'll be back and we'll hang out
after that'd be amazing what's like the
situation there they like going to be a
lot of it's a Halloween weekend at the
at at Resorts World just um artist
performance in
club slot holy [__] Vegas is already
crazy and then to like put that it's
it'll be fun it'll be fun yeah we'll be
sober we'll just [__] have a good
time hang out maybe basically shoot the
[__] like this on drugs at a
club have you ever podcasted on drugs
like heavy drugs not heavy drugs we've I
mean smoke in the bag sometimes uh never
done I don't think I've ever done a
podcast buzzed up I kind of want to D
sip a couple happy dads on Rogan really
protect our Park style yeah well maybe
not they go hard right yeah he was
drinking Bud Lights I wonder if he's
still doing that I I don't know how
people I just can't the smell the I got
that's not my thing I don't mind the Bud
Lights the beers they kind of taste a
little bit like kombuchas you ever do
kombuchas or no I do it yeah every now
and then you like it or not fizzy I like
it yeah I feel healthy yeah I feel like
Bud Lights like people get used to it
like cuz their dad drank it or whatever
it's like those strippers doing that
heal thing thing where they click I like
that yeah it's like why are you doing
that who's this Sexy D her quads are
just jiggling I'm like I don't really
care to see that see I'm into girls so I
like
it you likeing their balls shoes are you
into feet I'm not into feet I've never
really really but you're not like
grossed out by them are you not at all
I'll suck on a toe if they want me to
yeah I don't ever I've never looked at
feet and be like whoa I don't I don't
know I don't know about you like feet
don't no
doesn't Andrew sches like feet or am I
tripping I Andrew's cool huh you met
Andrew obviously I'm sure I've met him
yeah we haven't really talked but yeah
he was so in the moment he's funny as
[__] him I love Theo Theo's [__]
great Brian kin love Brian yeah and
Andrew and his little crew is funny
their show was so funny dude yeah the
was that the flagrant 2 or like their
comedy show we went to their show in
Phoenix yeah hell yeah pod's funny as
[__] too
yeah um yeah who who's the worst comic
out right now no
show who who in your opinion is the best
out right now comedian wise uh Shane
Gillis damn yeah Shane's funny as [__]
oh I met Shane at uh the UFC yep that
was cool he's a big guy bigger than I
thought yeah he can slam some DRS too
huh yeah he uh Joe choked him out or got
him in a couple arm bars do you see that
no recently yeah Jesus he talks about it
he's like I thought could take him I
can't take him that's so funny about
Bobby Lee I feel like you and Bobby Lee
look alike I
mean I mean yeah Bob both bro Bobby's so
funny I've only gave him one hug I've
never really got to hang out with him
I've never got to meet him oh really
yeah damn I saw him and I I did I did
like a little bow and then he was like
what bro you and Bobby would be funny
yeah in that live show on Phoenix when
you went on stage he flashed his [__]
his little wiener yeah that sh was funny
it did the live Miler because for kill
Tony you can it's live but it's not live
right I mean it's filmed but not live
right and people put their phones away
yeah so you could say some [__] that you
can take off or is there somebody always
kind of recording no they'll take out
anything you
want okay yeah some people over abuse
that power but yeah some guest yeah some
gu are who usually does I can't say who
I'll tell you after but someone just
mouth it
someone mou it when
I oh I wonder who else is going to be on
the up there tonight if anyone I think
it should just be you guys or you I mean
I'd be down with that but Michael bis
Mike bis bising was on it that one was
Hamed huh yeah and David Lucas was like
what are you looking
at David better not [__] roast me
I'll beat his ass no I actually want him
to I hope he says something on my long
skinny
neck you should should uh check out that
video that he has wrestling Tony where
he gets owned by Tony seen I've seen it
yeah I've seen that video I think I
watched it during the I was watching the
podcast and then they played the clips
of it oh I'm pump to meet Red Band too
you ever hang out is the nicest yeah is
he really kind of green or is that just
like the camera angles green like
color-wise like he's decaying he has
like a he has like a tint of green to
his skin I think it's his uh fuzz his
like 5:00 shadow just looks kind of
showered yeah he's a nice guy he's so
he's so sensitive and beautiful yeah
yeah he's a man he's got a cute girl too
yeah his girlfriend's amazing
too yeah she she's probably going to be
there Brian's going to be there for sure
yeah Brian's so nice he's always got my
back Brian Simpson's great no Brian Red
Man Brian Simpson doesn't usually go
okay but who is who are your favorite
guests on kill Tony um that's a good
question uh favorite guests I like Mark
Norman so much he's just the [__] he
says is so [__] autistic and funny I
love it Mark's one of my favorite um who
else who what about you I'm trying to
think right off the top of my head right
now thought Theo was good Theo good I
mean for the regulars though you and I
love Williams Williams Williams is
always good yeah David I love when David
gets up there William is just so funny
just naturally when he goes like this
Reas he
goes that shit's funny bro um good who
else I don't know caught me out guard
asking I don't know my favorite scar
brothers from back in the day I don't
think I've seen any of those the scar
brothers are so good maybe scar yeah
they're twins and they do this weird
thing where they like play off each
other like one will start a sentence and
the other will finish it damn I was
trying to get Tim to sit up there with
me but he's too
nervous yeah you're more the cool guy in
the corner just scoping it out that's
how that's Tim at the club looking for
the drunkest girl to [__] take see
the sweetest asses everyone else is
trying to grind God I hope there's no
sexy com uh comedians up there cuz I
start I just get horny it's distracting
I know that's funny though you should be
like hey I'm just sitting there going
like this why she doing her thing does
your girl get pissed when you guys talk
when you talk about like relationship
stuff up there or what does she say
she's like you why why did you say
that been there
brother been there brother yeah they
have they have their own goals like they
want to have like a nice relationship
and I want to like say the [__] up
[__] that's how I am yeah I mean yeah
[__] yeah I mean you can't just always
be like yeah my relationship's good we I
come home every day at 9: and wake up
give her massage yeah you got to say
some of the nasty [__] like that's they
want to hear yeah I agree we got to get
runchy a bit Yeah my girlfriend and I
have started dirty talking nice see I
love that it's just like as soon as we
start doing that I'm probably going to
bust probably 30 to 45 seconds yeah why
cuz it's like oh it's so I love you no
it's not like that's not dirty talking
that's my dirty talk when she says [__]
me Daddy or says I'm going to come daddy
or I love you like him oh that's
hot I've been there though those are
good the p passionate actually I'm not
allowed to talk about my stuff anymore
yeah he's got I mean just in general
like sex is pretty cool oh the cat's in
here I'm
addicted to [__] no I'm not I got that
I got that under control mhm um yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I think uh yeah my
girlfriend is great she's like uh you
know she we she used to be quiet and now
it's more getting more noisy so that's
good like sexually yeah she seems like
an innocent good girl I was like pretty
impressed I was like damn she's I didn't
know what to expect I didn't know if
she's going to be white or yeah what
that's the only thing I talk about oh
you saw
that up you're lucky you [__] she's
lucky she's
white just hit the brown parts of her
don't let that get to I thought youd
have I thought you'd have like a fet or
something this is Brian Simpsons cat oh
she loves you yeah God their but holes
are so [__] disgusting d don't use
that to cover [__] that thing was
looking right at me I'm a puked it's got
like little it's got chocolate chips on
it you're blowing on it you're snarling
at the cat yeah don't get that butle in
my
straw I'm not looking at it h gross it's
got blueberries on her butthole that
thing looks a little wider I think Brian
Simpson liked that thing
huh cat guys does Brian Simpson have a
girl no probably why he has a cat yeah
no I'm kidding I he was on Rogan
recently he's a pretty [__] smart
dude he's intell at least he just makes
[__] up that I like okay what do you
think about the UFOs and all the [__] I
I I think uh I just love I love
listening to smarter people talk about
UFOs but I feel like if I get asked
about them I don't have anything
interesting to say or any interesting
thoughts what do you think about it I
don't think they're real really I think
if aliens didn't exist people would make
it up about the same degree as to what
they're doing now it makes sense tracks
so do you think Jesus is real no I mean
I think he might have existed but I
don't think he's the think the red seed
parted two that was Moses but yeah no I
don't think that happened but still like
the whole thing no yeah yeah religion is
a weird one he's Jehovah's Witness still
to this day wow yeah he knocks on doors
and still preaching really are you
kidding no you're like no he's raised
that way though right in Arizona
Arizona's close to all that he was in
Montana right yeah Montana you were
never oh [__] were you ever religious at
any point yeah I we're Korean Christians
we praised the Korean Jesus no way yeah
he cuz I have a white I'm white
Christian and we had I wonder if they're
like the same or if they were like Kore
Jesus huh I like the sounds of that is
it the same story though like got hung
on the cross and stuff Korean ways
yeah he got hung next to a bunch of
bullgogi yeah got uh that's crazy yeah
religions interesting one I be joking
about it but some people I mean it's
[__] their life which I get I mean it
gives them a purpose I feel like it's
good for my mom helps her kind of like
navigate through life it's good for moms
cuz they don't have anything else to do
they can't [__] they're my mom she his
mom [__] my mom's a [__] Christian a
Christian that [__] your mom's a
[__] she she just asked for
forgiveness and she's fine yeah right
your mom's your mom works at a mattress
store I'll leave it at that she getting
cloud of the days yeah right swear to
God yeah right no I [__] his mom once
no I would though Margie I know I'm
kidding let's not bring names
into no
Michelle's isn't your girl's name
Michelle no oh no our Uber driers girl
his name what's your girl's name
again o that's close to Michelle no to
Karen oh yeah Karen do you ever call her
that when she's acting up if she starts
acting up say settle down Karen I
mean that's a good one huh how does she
live from here like uh 17 minutes 20
minutes you ever sneak out like what do
you mean like when she's sleeping yeah
that's what I tried to do last night but
she caught me and I had to bring her
then she sat in the car at the strip
club yeah do you ride your scooter there
to her house no it's a little too far
but I could do it I was wondering if it
was 17 on the scooter or just 17 on the
car 30 minutes by scooter yeah it's kind
of far to get some [__] py on the
highway do you sleep over there much
yeah all the time time yeah yeah I have
to I have to be the one that does that
cuz she has a normal job she doesn't
want to come stay here with four guys
yeah what does she do for work she is in
a office job like works for a company
that helps companies like send products
to the right
places so like you make sure you have
the enough nuts and bolts to fix an
elevator it break
interesting interesting oh yeah
what's uh what's your thoughts on uh
comedy the comedy scene in Austin Well
we haven't we haven't got it we drove
past [__] couple of the places on the
on the scooters last night um but we
haven't gone inside anywhere we've never
really we're going to tonight's our
first night experience in it excited to
see it we drove the birds around that
Sixth Street and the amount of bars was
crazy there was no one there though it
was crazy there was all open the DJs
were going the Bars were up but there
was like no one in them literally it was
like 11:30 yeah yeah they all do that
it's like a memory from the weekend when
everyone was in there like oh yeah this
is what we were doing last night but
then no one's in there it would have
been fun if there was
some stank some stuff there some stank
puss some stank puss going on but that
uh Uber driver was talking about the
what's going on downtown that guy that's
stealing people oh the Wrangler the the
Rainy Wrangler serial killer is he still
out and about yeah he hasn't killed
anyone in a while but there were men
showing up dead in the in the river and
no one has checked William Montgomery's
Alibi they say that they're all probably
drunk and kill themselves by being
idiots and you just fall in the river
yeah I mean I've been blacked out a few
times so I could see that yeah I mean
chances are that place is crazy it's
just like a riot every weekend and every
night yeah 6 Street it's going to be
pretty crazy tonight even if it's a
Monday it wasn't at all last night just
cuz everyone's at home for praying for
forgiveness or what I guess so well
maybe it won't be as busy tonight but it
always seems crazy seems like everyone's
just having fun like their life depends
on it it's kind of like an unhinged Vibe
that's good yeah so you're telling me
there's going to be some sexy chicks out
tonight yeah kill Tony I hope I have a
good
fit you could just wear your own clothes
oh really you're going to wear something
well I mean I'm just going to wear
clothes but I got like I I plan for
events nice got a little fish yeah a lot
of the UFC guys do like Connor yeah it's
like a thing it's not cool to be a slob
anymore unless you're kabib yeah yeah
well I I feel I'm little slobbed out
right now I mean I feel like women would
say like you got to look you know you
got the same color at the Hat yeah I
mean I I definitely matching a bit I
don't dress like that's all it takes for
men just to be the same color just
matching socks with their hat or
something yeah yeah girls go all out and
match their underwear to their
[__] God you know do you like skirts
yes dude skirts oh I love just imagining
doing one of these y y and we talked
about it before it's like sometimes
maybe girls naked aren't even that hot
but when they have those clothes on it
just wraps it and it just makes you
wonder yep the clothes definitely like
yeah cuz we usually don't see women
naked so all the hottest women we we've
seen are probably in clothes
yeah yeah in real life I mean yeah
skirts and a pigtail though
like hell thinking school girl just yeah
getting bad grades cheerleader oh shit's
distracting yeah yeah but post not you
not and you're good for about 15
minutes might as well be a dude yeah
oh yeah um well yeah I mean I think uh
certain women can be sexy naked like
some women are naked and it looks like
they're wearing clothes it's like going
on there I've seen that yeah I've seen
that not a huge fan Tan Lines yeah yeah
a lot of white women are getting tan
nowadays they like I appreciate that
yeah I think it's healthier that's one
thing I wish I could get little tan God
if I could get tan I would be so much
hotter he would go from like a seven to
a 7.5 exactly tall I mean dark and
handsome
yeah with red
head have you ever met a red head that's
tan uh I've seen a couple I've seen a
couple but it's mainly been on like uh
like amomi and fit that's filters yeah
that's unnatural those glasses are sick
I'm glad I didn't lose them thank you
that's how you get skin cancer yeah [__]
tanning beds and [__] yeah Hans look
cool in these glasses thank you man I
love the sides it's like it's like a
geography there's like topography on
there that's what that's the selling
point Dam let me take a pick that's far
imagine that do that [__] roll rolls
on stage with those I start buying
things is your is your Rolex your
biggest purchase uh it was a
gift that's far yeah I thought you
rolled into the Rolex ad and bought
one I know that's a different kind of uh
ownership of the thing because then it's
like I made a choice the to care about
myself and all that but it was a gift I
was like uh honor I felt honored cuz now
like when I wear it I wear it all the
time it's like you know this is
something that was bestowed upon me I
have a status now yeah and that's really
cool yeah I like that what was your
biggest purchase uh probably my gaming
computer that I'm never in town to use
there yeah I got a nice gaming computer
too I just don't use anymore this [__]
loves his I know what's what do you play
on it I just like getting on there with
the boys getting in some war zone
battles there's four of us or three of
us we play Call of Duty we drop in we
does it feel like real war it really
does and it feels like you just want to
get [__] crazy in there but uh I
stream so we got to keep it a little bit
PG but when we have the cleanse streams
yeah when you just can just say whatever
you want you die and you can just let
whatever words come out just Express
yourself yeah your true genuine
authentic
self no that's not true [__] what's uh
what's your strategy for a real war are
you like getting good at it uh real war
real war I'll probably hit up my
girlfriend's dad to go to his house
or just
hide that's smart I mean you guys are
well versed in violence so you know I
mean hand to hand yeah but when weapons
come into play yeah you have you have a
pistol or anything yeah I have a little
pistol I'm going to pick you for my
thumbnail here for pretty close to the
looks good you got a pistol ready to go
under your bed yeah it's under under a
lock you know how to you know how to
pump it and yeah I've been practicing
like an autistic
person in your room and
stuff oops
sorry hi
Brian Brian your cat a
butle um God I'm [__] pumped for
night killed Tony live I we've been
talking about for a while pump for this
trip I want is that awesome you guys get
to be on any show that you want to be on
yeah it is pretty [__] cool I
wouldn't mind being on uh Family
Feud jokes jokes jokes that show's
boring compared to killtony you got
offered like
say 50,000 cash to go on a a a six or
3-month reality show would you go
three months yep
50k and it's going to be a good time
that's all they're going to say it's
love on the Spectrum yeah I love that
it's going to be data [__] it's going
to be on Netflix Oh God would you go
yeah [__] I'd pretend to be autistic and
like try to [__] a woman that's disabled
bro that bro that one show that came out
I forgot it was on Discovery or whatever
but when the moms were going to look for
love and they got put in in there with
all their sons who were remember that
yeah that was [__] up oh those moms
were so horny you watch that one I I
heard about it I I I saw Clips my
girlfriend was watching it I was like it
was good that's what girls love to watch
is people trying to [__] each other just
drama I know they love drama but they
don't don't want
drama and then they don't actually want
to watch people [__] they just want to
watch people try to [__] and get close
to [__] yeah it's like that's so
weird
you good at warming up your girl or you
not you just kind of pump her and be I
yeah I I like I like molesting my
girlfriend and treating her like she's
just like a random passenger on the bus
I like that [__] too I think molesting
that means she would be a little
younger you can molest old people wait I
don't know if you can is molesting or
rape the same thing molesting is just
touching a definition of molesting yeah
I'm surpris you don't got that [__]
saved at a bookmark assault or abuse
especially a woman or a child okay woman
or child not a man though you can't
molest a man I don't I mean boy I guess
a boy is a child huh but you could
definitely molest a man you've done
it I got molested at some meet and
greets he was charged with obscene
photographs of a
boy so yeah
molesting that say it's a mindset jokes
um well should we [__] wrap her so we
can make sure we got some [__] velvet
yeah velvet talks [__] Hans Kim
appreciate you having us on the the
[__] what what do you don't call it a
podcast you just call it chatting with
Hans or something a chat cast little
chat cast uh do you ever do you post it
on the YouTube yeah I got a couple of
them up there right now this one I'll
try to come out with the uh when when
the kill Tony comes out in 3 weeks so
that three not two three yeah damn okay
yeah thanks man yeah [__] it Hans pump
see you tonight uh yeah thank you
brother fun love it